[音楽]
連れてこられました今日
まじつあるですね自分で解き方をですね
てるので年
今から解きます今日あのやることは全部口で説明するようにします
ペットですか
タレント
エキストラグラフィックえっ
い
下手がえーっと一塁ベースね上手が n bass しましょう
今が野球をします野球ルールはわからなくてもいい
盗塁というのはあるでね
えっ僕が一塁から二塁へ走ります
走っから
えっとその時に気づいたら
僕をあのアウトにしなければなりますだからこの中の狂気ている人の中の誰か一人が
走ったと言ってください
英語だと
ランジャス弾
でも a 棟
でちょっと練習しますねー
対バン
re 事件
はいこうなりますよねこれでへと
複製な人が知ったって言うからそれはだめー
累犯です
なぁで誰か一人越冬引いたと言ってください
でえっ
重複したら生
政府になったら僕のセッション終わりです
あの時間がありますけどセッションをワインにします
だから僕の話は期待に高かったらあの
必ずアウトにしないと終わっちゃいますよ
あっとは何かあるかな
あと1点愛ルールは
よっしゃ組は
プリプレイボール
さてへ
それですねー
僕もやっぱり話したい人だからアップで撮る
ここまではこれ一塁ベースですよ
ここべ程度だから見えてないとダメだからここからソチに走るということで気付いたら
入ってくださよね
皆さんの勇気が
勇気と調整力とあと何か諸々のそういうなんか糞みたいなが影響してるんでね
ラム服複数の人が言ったら訓示
まあまあそんな僕はねぇ
やっぱ後時間いっぱいしゃべりたいですから
船簡単に
雷の自分で自分のチャンスをふいにすべてのしたくないとき
ちょっと焦らせながらねやりますよ
これは制服やリードね
で
話しながらねー
やりましょうかねわかって言ったりいったけるかね
francfranc
で今ネット
[音楽]
アセトンとにカンペ
あっはいはい
エットっ
今日はねあそね編あの声おっきすぎるから大丈夫
さっきねランチの時に
あの他のスピーカーたちと盛り上がって全部話してしまったので
えっもう頭の中は空っぽなので何もないです
おっ
あと
そうだねー
何も頭の中にないと
こういう表情になります
なんかいじってパフォーマンスやない話してるつもりなんでねぇ
あんで僕が今ハマっていることあのプロゲーム簿2ってあったじゃないですかちょっと
1回ルール無視しますね
えっとああ
僕の話をまあ簡潔に言うと後読んでね
あの出自とされると何かから僕追い詰めだと僕がすごい自信を失っているわけだ
ねっ
こういう感じだなぁ
おいお前ラン
入っちゃったかなこれも取るしてたからそれで
僕に対して俺が言いたい事があるんで
やっぱりへ
ついてくれない
一応できない
ちょっとやっぱり
は研究をする
もう一回言いますけど僕が走ってへと走ったで何か1人元へ
言って成功になったら
それは
どちらも
どえっと
それは終わるのかな
まあやってみよ
よねー
記憶したらアウトね安西1
セグなた終わりです
あー緊張するとおいしく
そこからここまでの間にみんなが走っかって言ったらみんなこちらから
感覚かー
ハマるということは
放っていることがねえ今はって
これ磨くという
ちょっとまたゲームを中断します
これ何もないパンなんですけどこの子をマジ話していました
今ファンを買って苦くね磨くんですよ医学とやっぱりこの猫傘なされますよあとあのね
こう磨くとやっぱり磨くっていうのて使うからも手で考えた方がいいに頭じゃなくて
本当にもね
dna で考えた場合マジでそれでこうやって話す上回6点がやるでしょ
4薄まず構造ラージョねみんな見て判定後ロールパンなんだけどこれねあの
医学方法が高校がある訳これ阿南町かなうーんあの木目みたい
お勧めって事なんですけどっなあ本当に不思議なものでこう
ディティールがやてぃどうしようとか考えないって本当にあるんです
これで
これ
すごい所を開くでほしい人はところでございますからね
今日のプレゼンツですかねこれヤスリさんにクレバーに c 32分8ねやす立よね
簡単にと猫の研磨するよね
あの湯のえっと
研磨するよねそうやっぱり傷をつけやすいとにあったジャンジャケッ
ああ待て筋鉄な法律ってなんだよ
きっとここなるって言うよね
8を削る削るん
結構感じかな時間が生まれあの僕ねえよって1か月前に旅に出たんですよ
子どもたちとへ
8宮崎駅から a 賞の岬まで雨言っちゃいけないのかなこれ
行ってみますそれでいたいだねひたすら寝廊下書に載ってたんじゃ
そんでまあヒットする時間も歌いまして
それ
なんかねそのあのねなんて言うのかなその他デー賞だっとすればこうでしょ
ここがツール通路でこっにも立ちになる理由そしてこう電車が行為で初演車高で風客を
通り過ぎていく
自分自身が時間になってほ風景は今なんかちょっと走っていくとそ自分は時間になる4
時間ある
時間って
今僕中にいるから僕が風景になったと時間にすごい考える
それであのあれだよだからそれでもう一つ僕はその山にねあのアンのステップのああ
そこでポッっ
エットっ
もってもっ
それでえっとちょっと困った時はゲームに戻ると
よっ
じゃないぞ
それでですねー
本当に
嬉しいなぁ今日は皆聞いてくれて
だからねぇ
やっぱ0
うん
さんとお会いできるのって
苦味をよく系
人と比べて落ち込んでもいい
比べなければ自分がわからないああまいった途中から
んふーん
あまり踏まれはまりされで鬼浜でハマるのだ磨きにが夢で私はやはりアーティスト使っ
ちゃったかけられこれ6時はこれは80005千万
ポリッジプレイバリバリチェーンだ
でっこ飯
タイム調整だったよね
ああ
合わせさあ
おめでとうあなたたちの勝ちだよく覚えてバーン
これは何かなるのかなこれ